[Music]
Snowcap mountains, green valleys,
peaceful rivers, and rich culture. This
is Nepal. Not only a feast for the eyes,
but also home to hundreds of thousands
of upland and lowland farmers who depend
on rice for their food needs. Many of
these farmers are economically and
socially marginalized and are often the
poorest.
Traditionally, Nepalese hill farmers
rely on rice production for subsistence.
Most of them grow traditional varieties.
The average rice yield in Nepal has been
around 2 and 1/2 tons per
hectare. Upland rice farming is highly
labor inensive and taxing especially for
women. Besides their household chores,
women do most of the farm work such as
taking care of animals, weeding, drying,
and milling.
[Music]
The lack of new modern varieties,
quality seeds, and better crop
management technologies, and limited
access to public services are just some
of the many concerns of upland farmers.
[Music]
The International Fund for Agricultural
Development or Ephad provided funding to
the International Rice Research
Institute to implement a project in
Nepal. The project is called managing
rice landscapes in the marginal uplands
for household food security and
environmental
sustainability. In the mountainous areas
of Nepal, farmers grow rice in both
upland and lowland fields. The project
is focused on developing improved
technologies for managing these rice
landscapes. The project has adopted a
farmer participatory approach. Farmers
are highly involved from the beginning
during implementation and in the
decision making
process. Research on potential
technologies is conducted at
village-based field research sites. It
is done with a collaboration of the
farmers and national research
organizations. The project in Nepal
collaborates with the Lumjang campus in
Sundar Bazar of the Institute of
Agriculture and Animal Sciences or
IAS and the National Rice Research
Program or NRRP of the Nepal
Agricultural Research Council in
Kathmandu.
In this video, we shall see the
technologies that were identified,
tested, and disseminated under the
project. It will also show how the
farmers benefit from these
technologies. IAS researchers with a
collaboration of the farmers identified
and tested several suitable upland and
lowland rice varieties.
From these varieties, farmers chose
Radha 32 and
IR554355. These farmers came from
several villages in Langjong, Gorka and
Tanahun
districts. Radha 32 can be grown in both
the lowland and upland.
[Music]
Another variety
IR554355 has consistently outperformed
the preferred local varieties. Farmers
like it because of its higher number of
field grains and straw yield. Farm
animals like the soft straw. The straw
feeds farm animals such as cattle and
buffalo during the dry season.
From the IAES assisted areas, we have
seen and heard the reasons why farmers
preferred and adopted the varieties
mentioned compared with
others. Let us now travel to East Nepal.
The National Rice Research Program
assisted area of the project is in
Mahutari district which has two research
sites Pu and
Bapsi. Here farmers preferred NR
6015, RHS
397,
BM9855 and hard enough one. Farmers
chose these varieties for their higher
yield, good eating quality and
suitability to a rice cropping pattern.
The M9855 and NR 6015 also perform well
in rainfed land and irrigated
conditions.
[Music]
The ability to grow spring rice is a
blessing for farmers in the lower hills
because they can grow two crops in one
year, one in spring and one in the
summer.
Hard enough one is the most popular
spring season variety in the Churia
Hills. The variety is popular because it
matures early which allows growing a
second crop. Hard enough one is also
high yielding and has good milling and
eating qualities. It is also tolerant of
drought and major rice
diseases. The project distributed hard
enough one seeds to farmers in Bapsi and
Pu villages. The seeds were also
distributed to farmers in seven
neighboring districts with a
collaboration of the district
agricultural development offices for
varietal demonstration and wider
dissemination. Good quality seeds are
important inputs of production for
farmers. Farmers rely on good seeds for
their next harvest. in the IAES assisted
areas. The project helped enterprising
farmers to organize themselves into
commercial seed production and marketing
groups. Thus far, two groups have been
formed, one in Lamjung district and the
other in Tanahun. The groups are
producing rice and maze seeds.
The two groups were provided with
information on group formation and
government assistance, technical advice,
training on scientific seed production,
technical monitoring and supervision of
seed production plots and knowledge on
seed
[Music]
marketing. These efforts have increased
the capacity of farmers to produce
seeds. This has also helped them to
market and meet local demand for the
popular varieties. This endeavor has
improved the availability of good
quality seeds of new and old popular
varieties in the
area. Seedling broadcasting, a
laborsaving technique as opposed to
transplanting, was also recommended to
farmers in
2007. The method saves them up to 60% in
labor compared with traditional
transplanting. It has significantly
lessened the backbreaking job of
transplanting.
[Music]
The project in collaboration with
community-based farmer groups and
district offices also introduce crop
diversification options such as seasonal
and offseason vegetable
growing. One can see the farmer's
kitchen gardens filled with vegetables
such as cabbage, cauliflower, tomato,
broadleaf mustard, cucumber, sponge
gourd, and radish.
Farmers such as Ki, Kushiram, Kalpana,
and others say that aside from rice on
their table, they also get added income
from the vegetables they grow. Cash
income from vegetables has enabled these
farmers to buy food and other items for
their families.
As the project ends in 2009, upland
farmers in Nepal have become more aware
of new rice varieties and technologies
and have started adopting those that
suit their needs. They are now growing
vegetables which translates into cash
income.
They know now whom to approach when they
have questions on crop technologies and
their firsthand experience in doing
research with the scientists has
enriched their local
knowledge. As farmers continue to adopt
and share the technologies they
developed, we hope that more upland
farmers in Nepal will not only have
enough food on their table but also have
extra income for their famil family's
needs. Now that is what we mean by hope.
[Applause]
[Music]